[музика]
Добрий вечір в ефірі програма кутзору
гість студії Міністр освіти і науки
України Лілія Гриневич Вітаю вас у нашій
студії Лілія Михайлівна Щиро вітаю вас і
усіх глядачів сьогодні в нашому
агроуніверситеті відбулася дуже важлива
подія от я зачитаю заключни тренінг
першого етапу це розвитку інклюзивної
освіти в рамках соціальної програми
Марина Порошенко Марини Порошенко от
разом з дружиною президента ви були на
цьому заході Які ваші враження
ее суспільство рівень своєї
цивілізованості демонструє тим як він
став як воно ставиться до людей з
особливими потребами до людей з
інвалідністю А якщо це маленькі діти з
особливими потребами То тим більше е на
превеликий жаль е впродовж детиріч Ці
діти як правило знаходились на
індивідуальному навчанні або в
спеціалізованих закладах і були
ізольовані від суспільства в результаті
е ми
втратили вміння спілкуватися з ними і ми
недооцінюємо яким великим благом може
бути таке спілкування і які насправді
можуть бути абсолютно непересічні
особистості і люди які будуть впливати
на життя в цій країні з таких дітей так
от ін вна освіта вона спрямована на те
щоб таких дітей включати в навчання у
звичайних школах і зараз цим опікується
Марина Порошенко дружина Президента і я
справді як Міністр освіти дуже вдячна їй
за це тому що це допомагає нам це
питання поставити першочергово зокрема
перед місцевою владою і мені дуже
приємно що сьогодні це відбувалося тут у
Житомирі було дуже багато освітян люди
які прекра прекрасно розуміють ці
проблеми які виявили свій
рівень освіченості в цьому тому що
насправді наших вчителів сьогодні не
готують до того як працювати з дітьми з
особливими потребами коли вони приходять
до звичайного класу ну от цікава ваша
думка з такого приводу А який світогляд
наскільки широкий світогляд має молодь
Сьогодні мають знання от Ну наприклад
порівняно з тим часом Коли ви навчали у
Львівському університеті або потім
викладали в школі от з тим періодом що
змінилося Звичайно що молодь сьогодні
інша ніж була тоді в минулому столітті
сьогодні Це так зване покоління Z це
покоління яке зростає серед розмаху
інформаційних технологій
яке є так би багато задачне вони можуть
думати водночас про багато речей вони
користуються інформаційними технологіями
шука кають інформацію У нас сьогодні є
такий цифровий розрив між поколіннями і
дуже часто викладачі не вміють того
робити Що вже вміють студенти і так само
вчителі і діти
і тому сьогодні вчитель і викладач має
по-іншому готуватися до процесу
викладання тому що ці діти швидше
реагують Ці діти не готові брати участь
в нудному процесі навчання і неуникнено
система освіти мусить змінюватися разом
з ними тому що вся ця система освіти
працює заради цих дітей а не діти заради
того щоб задовільнити систему Ну от
свого часу я знаю ви стажувалися в
університетах Варшави і Колумбії
сполученіх Штати Америки так от який
досвід який ви там бачили досвід їх
роботи можна перенести сюди запозичити і
головне втілити Чи взагалі це можливо з
освітою є така ситуація що неможливо
взяти і скопіювати якусь практику
освітньої системи одної країни в іншу
країну тому що освіта має дуже серйозний
національний контекст те що сидить в
національній ідентичності людей в тому
як вони взагалі ставляться до освітнього
процесу і виховання
історія політичні проблеми які є мовні
проблеми от в нас зараз навіть в на якщо
ми дивимось на Україну як країну то та
до Майданна Україна і післямайданна
Україна дуже відрізняється і ми під це
маємо сьогодні розвивати систему освіти
бо якщо ми зробили нарешті свій вибір
євроінтеграцію і ми розуміємо Куди ми
йдемо і наші амбіції бути європейцями не
просто європейцями які на цьому
континенті а ввійти до Європейського
Союзу Разом з тим ми поряд маємо країну
яка виявилась агресором А ми Вважали її
братньою країною яка сьогодні убиває
синів українського на народу і це теж
треба брати під увагу і розуміти що роль
патріотичного виховання зростає інша
справа що ми маємо ще й поділену країну
в нас є окуповані території і нам треба
зрозуміти як як ми маємо
об'єднатися як ми маємо навчитись
розуміти одне одного тобто нові виклики
і ці виклики стоять перед системою
освіти тому що дитина або змалечку цьому
всьому вчиться бо привнести це же для
дорослої людини змінити повністю її
світогляд дуже складно зверху це може
відбутися тільки через якісь зміни які
доросла людина пережила сама ми з вами
всі хто брали участь в тих подіях хто
втратив своїх близьких чи друзів ми
стали вже іншими і зараз нам важливо е
переформатувати систему освіти А головне
цілі завдання які Вона ставить перед
собою От наприклад в середній освіті
дивіться ми впродовж років Ідемо шляхом
накопичення нової нової інформації і ми
зараз в дітей заштовхуємо таку величезну
кількість інформації що вони втомлюються
від цього вони випадають з процесу
навчання вони знеохочуються до школи
питання Ця інформація вся потрібна для
них чи вони використовують її для життя
всі провідні системи освіти сьогодні
працюють під одним дуже простим гаслом
освіта для життя тобто людина здобувши
загальну середню освіту повинна бути та
такою яка готова до вирішення будь-якої
життєвої проблеми позитивного вирішення
не сховатися в собі втекти від цієї
проблеми тому світ же визначив перелік
ключових компетентностей для сучасної
людини XX століття і окрім рідної мови
двох іноземних мов інформаційних
технологій те що для нас очевидно там є
такі компетентності як вміння критично
мислити вміння працювати в команді
фінансова грамотність підприємництво
культурна компетентність і це
здобувається не за рахунок збільшення
кількості знань це здобувається за
рахунок при внесення в зміст освіти
завдань з життя які діти повинні
навчитися вирішити і математику можна
підпорядкувати таким завданням не
вивчати десятиповерхові логарифмічні
рівняння а навчити дітей користуватися
статистикою аналізувати явища
порахувати відповідно свою спроможність
організовувати бюджет родинний І що ти
можеш очікувати від банківської системи
тобто нашим дітям сьогодні не вистачає
саме цих практичних навичок сучасної
людини Ну так цей досвід от ви сказали
що у нас звичайно зрозуміло є
автентичність все але цей досвід е ну от
використати у нас можна в Сполучених
Штатах Америки Варшави фрагментарно
можна звичайно от я перепрошую лікарі
кажуть що от ми намагаємось бути за
стандартами працювати за стандартами
наприклад які є в Європі от Отже коли
коли я кажу про 10 ключових
компетентностей вони узгоджені країнами
Європейського Союзу і наш план зараз
змінити зміст української школи саме під
формування цих 10 ключових
компетентностей Тому що наші діти
відповідно повинні бути повноцінними
громадянами Європейського союзу а не
другосортними і це означає що вони
повинні мати таку ж готовність до життя
це великий і складний проект ЗМІ зміни
змісту освіти але ми розпочинаємо над
ним працювати в серпні буде представлена
концепція нової української школи
сьогодні уже в парламенті є закон про
освіту нова редакція і ми чекаємо щоб
парламент влітку проголосував цей закон
і
фактично розпочинається повномасштабна
робота над новими методиками викладання
бо це масове навчання вчителів Як
викладати такий новий зміст А щоб не
чекати так довго до запуску саме нової
школи Ми вже зараз влітку
переглядаємо програму початкової школи
для наших маленьких школярів з
привнесенням елементів власне такого
компетентнісного навчання про яке я вам
зараз говорила бо навчання особливо за
для цих дітей має відповідати їхнім
віковим особливостям і має їх
захоплювати і має розвивати їхній
емоційний інтелект на превеликий жаль в
програмі початкової школи це дуже добре
знають батьки таких діток є також
величезне перевантаження
різноманітною непотрібною інформацією
яка не відповідає їхнім віковим
особливостям я зараз вам процитую один з
підручників математики старих який ми
вже фактично зараз вилучаємо з шкільних
бібліотек але там наприкла наприклад є
таке визначення нуля нуль е
це тобто сам нуль описується через
множину в якій відсутні елементи цієї
множини тобто якщо дитина яка ще вчить
буквар у першому класі прочитає таке
визначення можна зрозуміти що ця дитина
починає думати в неї виникають комплекси
що вона чогось не розуміє а насправді не
розуміє ті люди які укладають подібний
підручник Мабуть тому і я математику не
знав Може колись прочитав так не
ви знаєте що це може насправді
знеохочувати цілі покоління ми зараз
спостерігаємо що в нас різко спала
якість математичної освіти і от Коли
випускники обирають зовнішнє незалежне
оцінювання з кожним роком скорочується
драматично кількість випускників які
обирають математику як профільний іспит
я на останньому дзвонику спілкувалася з
випускниками в одній з Київських шкіл і
я їх запитала підніміть будь ласка руку
ті хто іде на природничо-математичні
спеціальності двоє з двох класів підняло
руку і це є дуже тривожна тенденція і
особливо мене переконав один з
професорів який ее е викладав математику
і викладає математику і каже що якщо б я
навчався за сьогоднішньою шкільною
програмою математики я б ніколи не брав
це своєю спеціальністю на все своє життя
але знаєте про що я ще подумав от
спілкуючись що кожний новий уряд коли
приходить починає реформу освіти Я не
знаю Та ну медицина освіти от
започатковує це погодьтеся ви ж багато
років працювали в парламенті і в
комітеті який цим
опікується чому так
відбувається чи не втомились діти їх
батьки від реформувань які відбуваються
циклічно до
зміни Верховної Ради наприклад Чи
уряду Я мушу констатувати що справжнього
реформування за роки незалежності
України так і не було звичайно ми про Ми
цю радянську школу трансформували В
національну українську школу але реальне
реформування можливе тільки в першу
чергу через зміст освіти сучасний зміст
Ну от наприклад у Канаді на цим
компетентнісним підходом працюють 20
років і якщо я як міністр так і велика
команда людей зараз
започаткує тепер в Україні оновлений
зміст освіти то Зрозуміло що за
каденцією цього уряду чи навіть двох
підряд неможливо буде таку серйозну
реформу зробити бо освіта - це не та
сфера де ти можеш підкрутити два
гвинтики і все одразу зміниться і
глибокі зміни можуть іти Саме через
зміст і через підготовку тоталь
саме вчителів які закривають за собою
двері в клас і роблять те що вони
вважають за потрібне і які б не спускали
їм циркуляри якщо Вчитель до цього не
готовий то учень не відчує цієї реформи
І от що я хочу сказати що в багатьох
країнах існує таке правило оскільки в
системі освіти працюють тільки
довготривалі реформи домовляються
політичні сили між собою що незважаючи
на зміни
уряду виконується та стратегія яка була
започаткована попереднім і це дуже і
дуже важливо Так я дуже сподіваюся що
коли буде концепція цієї нової
української школи і новий закон про
освіту коли вони пройдуть в парламенті
це буде та дорожня карта якою Будемо іти
цей уряд наступний уряд і продовжуватись
оця головна змістова реформа і оновлення
методик навчання дітей знаєте що ще
батьків так Ну те що турбує але просто
про це йде розмова
що кожного разу знов таки кожна Верховна
Рада нова і чи уряд спочатку там 11
років навчання 11 потім 12 Ну от я
вчився 10 років Я не думаю я не знаю ви
теж мабуть десятирічку закінчували с
початку перед університетом я не думаю
що ми так вже менше знань здобули ніж ті
хто буде Чи буде чи не знаю 12 років
вчитися ми з вами жили зовсім іншу епоху
і ці 10 років на той час для нас
абсолютно вистачало Якщо ви подивитеся
зараз на інформаційний простір і на ту
кількість знань технологій і всього що є
і оточує сьогодні сучасну дитину це не
співмірно на порядки більше порівняно з
тим що оточувало наше з вами покоління
коли телевізор і радіо були єдиним дуже
вузьким джерелом інформації і зараз для
того щоб людина жила в цьому драматично
швидко оновлюючому себе світі Вона
мусить знати значно більше вона мусить
вміти критично аналізувати цю інформацію
сьогодні люди е в провідних країнах
світу змінюють впродовж життя три-чотири
рази свою професію здобувають по
декілька освіт весь час підвищують свою
кваліфікацію і тому дитина має навчитися
вчитися впродовж життя е на території
Європи 11-тирічка залишила тільки в
Україні Білорусі і Росії і чому Тому що
ми далі працюємо на відтворення знань
хоча кризу вже всі відчувають
перевантаження дітей всі відчувають і це
перевантаження призводить до того що
значна кількість дітей просто випадає з
навчання і не вчиться взагалі що в
результаті ми отримуємо маргіналізовані
групи молоді які потім не хочуть вчитися
Тому нам неуникненно доведеться
збільшувати тривалість навчання але я
хочу сказати всім і користуючись нагодою
і цим ефіром глядачам глядачам і батькам
що ніхто не буде додавати 12-й рік до
такої школи якою вона є сьогодні тому що
немає сенсу в такій школі сидіти ще один
рік і терпіти цю наругу цим потоком
фарширування знань знаєте як один класик
сказав напихати дитину знаннями аби вона
черговий раз римигнула ними на емені і
забула про них Ні це не є мета сучасної
школи ми можемо додавати 12-й рік лише
тоді коли Ми змінимо стандарти освіти
запустимо цей новий компетентнісний ЗМІ
зміст освіти щоб це навчання дійсно
принесло користь нашим дітям от тоді
якщо говорити про календар впровадження
12 річки то поки що в цій ситуації
фінансової скрути яка в нас є Ми
плануємо з
18-19го навчального року запускати
перший клас 12-тирічної школи це означає
що 12-й додатковий рік виникне для нас
аж в
29му-30му році хоч оптимісти і реалісти
е кажуть що це може бути орієнтовний рік
входження
України до Європейського до
Європейського Союзу і тоді в нас буде
повністю синхронізований освітній
простір середньої освіти але можуть бути
і більш оптимістичні варіанти якщо би
були кошти Якщо б нарешті завершилася ця
безглузда війна інспірована ее
сусідською агресивною країною то тоді б
ми могли запустити цю реформу швидше і
так само могли біти п'ятикласники але я
повторюю це має бути нова школа з новим
змістом і з новими методами навчання